Tim Ferriss: All right, John, nice to see
you, and welcome to the show.
John Romero: Well, thanks for having me.
I'm excited.
Tim Ferriss: I thought I would give a few
caveats for people listening.
Number one, I'm going to operate on the assumption
that most people have very little context
on your life story, so I will be asking a
lot of very basic questions.
And I extend my apologies to you and the hardcore
gamers out there, but I think that'll be helpful
for folks.
And some very, very long-term listeners may
recognize your name because it came up in
conversation with Alexis Ohanian, who is a
friend of mine, co-founder of Reddit, who
credits your story with helping inspire the
creation of that company.
And of course your story and the products
of your imagination and hard work have also
inspired many, many others.
The creation of Oculus VR and the cultural
touchstones and the influence of pop culture
over decades is really remarkable.
So in the process of doing my homework and
due diligence for this conversation, the expansive
nature of the impact is pretty mind-boggling.
But I want to start in the beginning, and
by beginning I mean childhood, because I'd
like to provide some connective tissue that
then leads into later questions.
Could you please just describe where you grew
up and what your childhood looked like?
John Romero: I grew up in Tucson, Arizona.
I was born in '67, so I did a lot of my early
years in the late '60s and the early '70s.
I grew up right next to the Yaqui Reservation,
and my families, on my dad's side, has Aztec
and Yaqui heritage, but we call ourselves
Mexicans and Mexican food was the food that
we all ate.
We lived in a pretty poor place.
I only lived in that area until about fourth
grade, but it was pretty culturally significant
to me because I really learned a lot of my
Mexican side at that time.
And then we moved.
My dad went to the grocery store and never
came back, and so my mom got a divorce and
then met a guy that was a military guy and
got married.
And then we moved to Northern California,
which was very, very different than the desert
in Tucson, Arizona.
Tim Ferriss: I would love to hear you expand
a little bit on your time in Tucson and your
experience with your biological father because
I think it paints perhaps a picture.
I was reading a piece in The Washington Post
that certainly made it seem very challenging,
that chapter of your life.
John Romero: I don't know how many generations
ago that is, but in human generations it was
a long time ago and people definitely acted
differently back then.
And I guess in the family and in just socially,
the circles that my dad ran around in, drinking
alcohol was like drinking water.
I never saw him actually drink water, it was
always beer.
And it wasn't just him, it was basically just
about everybody.
And people that drink usually will surround
themselves with other people that drink because
they like doing similar things together.
So everybody that I saw always drank.
And that always led to all kinds of crazy
stuff happening, because when you've been
drinking, you're going to be doing all kinds
of random stuff.
INTERLUDE
Tim Ferriss [to listeners]: At this point,
I think it might be helpful to provide a little
bit of context related to the hardships that
John endured and overcame in his childhood.
Because I think it informs who he is and speaks
to a toughness and resilience that is worth
underscoring.
So what I’m going to read is an excerpt
from a very good piece in The Washington Post
titled “Why revered developers John and
Brenda Romero started a game studio in Ireland.”
And here is that excerpt.
“John grew up in Tucson, Arizona.
His biological father was an alcoholic.
‘At that point in time, John would've had
burn marks on his arms, he would've seen his
mother getting beat up,” Brenda said.
[Brenda is John’s wife.]
Money and food were tight.
John’s father robbed stores at gunpoint
on multiple occasions to get diapers.
One day, when John and his younger brother
Ralph made a mess in the kitchen, his mother,
stressed, told John’s father to ‘get rid
of them.’
It wasn’t meant to be literal.
‘He just put us in the truck and drove us
out in the middle of the desert and told us
to get out and then took off,’ John said.
He was six.
Ralph was four.
John recognized where they were and decided
to follow the truck, spending a half-hour
in the desert until his mother made his father
bring them home.”
So this is one of quite a number of examples,
but I think it is worth including here simply
because it is part of the context that makes
John who he is.
And with that, back to the interview.
END INTERLUDE
Tim Ferriss [in conversation]: It seems like
when your mom met this military man, that
it was a real significant chapter shift and
shift of environment, shift of experience.
And I'm not sure how far ahead we'd be skipping,
but could you explain what Aggressor Squadron
was and how you became involved with that?
John Romero: The Aggressor Squadron was one
of the divisions on the military base that
he was stationed at in 1983.
That was a place where the pilots — this
is the Cold War, by the way.
The pilots are learning Russian flight maneuvers,
combat maneuvers, and the Aggressor Squadron
is where they all learned all of the flight
training, I guess, that they needed in case
they got in contact with Russians.
And the point was not to ever get in contact,
because this space was primarily a reconnaissance
space where they were flying U-2s and TR-1s
to do reconnaissance over Russia, to try and
find out what they're doing.
But in case something happened, they would
know what would to do.
So they flew a lot of other planes out of
there.
I think F-5s, a lot of F-5s.
And anyway, that was the place where he did
that.
When I started school halfway through — at
the beginning of 1983 but was halfway through
the school year of my sophomore year in school,
I could actually choose to take computer programming,
which is pretty great in the '80s.
Because it was halfway through the year, the
teacher had to approve that it was okay for
me to join because I was halfway through learning
BASIC.
But I already knew BASIC, I was finished with
BASIC and I was learning assembly language.
And when I talked to the teacher and showed
her that I knew assembly and that's why I'm
coding and I know everything about this machine
and all that, so she was really impressed
the first day that I got into school.
And the second day when I came to school,
she told everyone in the class what to work
on and then she told me to follow her, and
we went to her car and she drove me to the
Aggressor Squadron on base and introduced
me to Captain Spencer.
And he was Top Gun dude.
He was a total rocket jockey guy.
He ejected out over the Mediterranean, this
guy's done so much stuff.
Anyway, he went to a phone, and he said a
bunch of different code words into the phone.
And then this giant bank vault-looking door
opened, big round one, it opened and we went
inside of this vault vault, a bank vault-looking
thing.
It was in the middle of the Aggressor Squadron
where they keep classified stuff.
And they had already put away the stuff because
they knew that he was bringing someone in
that didn't have clearance.
And he took me to the back and I saw this
mini computer, it was a Cromemco, and he said,
"Here's our mini computer.
I'm just wondering if you knew how to program
it?"
And so I got on it and I noticed that it was
using the CPM operating system and that you
could program it in BASIC.
So I said, "Yeah, yeah, I know CPM and I know
BASIC."
He is like, "You've got yourself a job."
So basically I got a job the second day I
got to school just because of connections.
My teacher saw that I knew how to code and
then she ran into this guy later that day
and told him about me and he is like, "Bring
him on over."
So it was just really, really random.
Tim Ferriss: How did you get your very first
taste of computers?
When did you get bitten by the bug?
Given the humble beginnings where one would
assume, especially at that time, that it would
be very hard perhaps to come across or get
access to computers.
John Romero: Getting access to computers in
the '70s was basically not going to ever happen
in someone's house.
Computers weren't even in the home yet.
The personal computer revolution was just
barely beginning, so only thousands of people
in the United States may have had a computer
and they most likely built it themselves.
So computers were very early, they weren't
really in houses yet.
But in 1979, my friend — I was addicted
to arcades.
I played arcade games all the time, or pinball
or anything, because it was so much fun and
so different.
But it cost money and it's hard for a kid
who's 10 or 11 to actually have the money
to spend on arcades.
But my friend came to my house and said, "I
just found a way for us to play games that
doesn't cost any money."
And I'm like, "Oh, my God."
I jumped on my bike and I followed him, and
about a half an hour later we pedal up to
the Sierra College computer lab.
It's summertime in 1979, so I'm 11 years old.
And I just follow him and we go into this
computer lab, it's really nice and cold.
And basically he shows me this computer and
the computer, it's a mainframe in a room.
There's a room that's just got a giant computer
in it and there's these terminals, these black
and white TV screens with keyboards connected
to them.
And I mean, there's like one unit.
And so he starts showing me these really early
text games, and these text games are Hunt
the Wumpus and Star Trek and Poison Cookie
and these just really early, early games.
And I was just really impressed because I
didn't need to pump in quarters and I could
take my time with every move, I could just
think about it and then move.
That was very, very different.
So I played for a little while and I noticed
that there were only probably two students
in the room, and I said, "Well, what are they
doing on the computer, because it doesn't
look like they're playing?"
He goes, "Oh, no, they're programming."
And I'm like, "What is that?"
He said, "Well, that's actually what you do
to make these games.
You have to learn how to tell the computer
how to put stuff on the screen and what to
do, how to think."
And I'm like, "I want to do that."
So I just went over and asked one of the students,
"What does that mean?"
And it's like print statement and some other
stuff.
And he tells me what it is and I started asking
him some more questions.
"What does 'if' do, what does that mean?"
And so he is explaining it.
And eventually, because I'm asking too many
questions, he just gets me the book for BASIC
that's there and I just take it over to the
computer that I was on and I basically started
learning how to code.
And with nobody kicking me off the computer,
I'm sitting there with a book and I'm starting
to teach myself how to program a really basic
adventure, which goes from room to room, just
with a text description.
So basically, on a high level, it's kind of
crazy.
11-year-old goes to computer lab at the college
and teaches himself how to code.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's incredible.
John Romero: And so yeah, that's what I did.
And I didn't have a computer for three years
after that.
In the meantime I would go to any computer
store in my town or the next town, and if
they had a computer there, like Radio Shack
has a TRS-80 or something, I would sit down
and I would find one of the books that has
programming in it and I would just enter the
code into the computer and play around with
it and figure out if it doesn't work usually,
why it doesn't work, and try to fix it and
then change it.
And that's really slow learning.
But that was how I learned how to code in
my first introduction to computers was at
the college because I never saw them anywhere
else.
Tim Ferriss: Pedaling over.
And was the main interest, at that point,
I would assume the creation of games?
And I guess the follow on to that is, was
there something about programming that tickled
your brain in a particular way?
Was there something else intrinsic to programming
that appealed to you beyond the output, which
would be the games?
John Romero: Gaming was the only reason why
I wanted to start learning how to code because
I — thinking about arcade games, it was
like, "I have no idea how I would even make
that."
But looking at the games that I had played
on the mainframe was like, "I could probably
do that," because that's just really simple
stuff on the screen.
So when I could get things up on the screen
quickly and they kind of looked similar to
what I was playing, I was like, "I am totally
on the right track.
This is going to work."
So the interest was only to make games.
But one of the really interesting things about
programming, and especially back then, was
that the programming experience was extremely
immediate.
On computers back then you could turn the
computer on and it was ready to code, right
then.
There was no programs to run to code a computer,
it was ready.
So the iteration speed of learning was as
fast as it gets.
It's like, I could type something in and run
it.
And it either was going to bomb and tell me
there's something wrong or it's going to work
and I'm like, "I just learned something new."
So that iterative, that fast feedback, iterative
nature of programming, was really, really
conducive to keep my interest in learning
how to code and get better at it.
And yeah, it was just building on stuff very,
very fast.
Learning all the keywords, figuring out how
to put them all together to do certain things.
And not just solving problems, but I'm starting
to architect what I want to do.
And so there's these phases of learning where
you start to understand that anything that
you can think of, you can make it happen.
If you only you have the right words and the
right description to, "How do I put a thing
on the screen?"
Well, that's with print.
"How do I put it over there on the screen?"
And then it's like, there's some commands
for saying exactly how to get to that point
on the screen.
When you start breaking down all of these
little problems and you know how to solve
one of these little problems, you start to
have a lot of confidence that you can do what
you're hoping to do.
And that just makes you want to keep on going.
So solving problems really, if you're a person
who likes to solve problems, programming is
absolutely for you because your job and your
whole life is solving problems when you are
a beginning programmer.
You're climbing these walls constantly to
get over them and learn something and go do
the new thing.
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to leap forward a bit
and then we're going to go back and fill in
some of the gaps.
And I'm getting very much in the deep end
of my ignorance pool, so I'm going to need
you to lead me through what I'm about to read.
But I was talking to my brother last night
who codes, is involved with technology, and
he pointed me ultimately to a rabbit hole
that led me to a paragraph, this is going
somewhere, on gamerant.com, and I was hoping
you could explain what this means.
So, "John Romero ended up making the biggest
advancement in gaming since the invention
of the video game itself.
He was the first person to make a navigable
maze appear on a screen, giving gaming a third
dimension of movement."
We were just talking about problem solving,
and this may require some explanation on your
part, but could you walk us through the significance
of that and how it came to be?
John Romero: Computer games have been around
since the '70s.
And 3D games have also been around since the
'70s, so there were some really primitive
games.
But first-person, if we're talking about first-person,
which is where people really start to get
into 3D, there was really, really early games
in the — say, in 1974, is where 3D games
really start on mainframe computers, where
it's rendering a hallway scene and maybe a
character on the screen in front of you.
And when you move, you don't move smoothly,
you move by a chunk of the maze.
So it's a really primitive movement, but it's
like, it's rendered in 3D.
And not until we get to, say, Battlezone in
1980 does it become very smooth.
And Battlezone is line-drawn pyramids and
stuff in the back in the scene and, say, another
tank.
You're in a tank and there's another tank,
and they're smoothly moving and coming towards
you and you're having to use tank controls
to aim and shoot at it, and everything's coming
for you.
But it was a smooth-moving 3D, but it was
line-drawn.
So the advancements in 3D eventually get to
the point where you have solid filled walls
so it looks like a color, walls look a certain
color, so when you turn it's not seeing through
an invisible wall.
And then they start getting textures in the
mid '80s.
So if you play, say, Might & Magic, you'll
see it.
I think some Wizardry games also had it.
And even Ultima, when you go into the dungeons,
you'll see a rendered 3D view that has texture
on it, like someone drew a wall, like an actual
bricks or whatever.
But it doesn't move smoothly, it's moving
by chunks.
Still, on computers, it was a lot slower to
get to that point of smooth movement.
So when we started doing 3D in 1991, we did
do solid color walls, but we could move through
that maze perfectly smooth and turn any direction
we wanted to and see that maze in fluid, full,
high-speed 3D, which nobody had seen at that
point.
Our focus was on trying to make that happen,
the speed was the focus for us, getting 3D
moving quickly became — at least at that
point with that one early game, that was really
important for us.
It wasn't to do something really amazing with
the 3D, but it was just to get a 3D scene
drawing at high speed so you can turn around
in one second, you can just do a spin.
And that took a lot of computer knowledge
of the hardware of the computer.
And also how to draw a scene not using all
of the 3D equations that you normally would
use to compute a 3D scene, but restricting
the way that you could move to reduce the
amount of computation that you needed to do
to turn the scene into a scene that is visually
complex in 3D, do that very quickly, by not
having to worry about certain angles that
you would see, or turn your head or roll forward
or whatever.
So it restricted you to only one plane of
turning, where you're just rotating your head
around.
You can't look up and you can't look down
and you can't tilt your head sideways.
So by reducing your motion that way, it reduced
the kind of computations that we needed to
do.
Tim Ferriss: So if I'm hearing you correctly,
and I may not just because of my limitations
as a Luddite, or maybe not a Luddite, but
more of a muggle in this capacity, but it
seems like you applied positive constraints,
a number of constraints, so that you could
use, let's call it elegant code, to dramatically
improve the speed of the player experience.
And I'd love for you to explain two things
for people listening.
Number one, when you're saying "us," who is
"us?"
And why do you think you guys were able to
create this breakthrough instead of perhaps
other teams?
Or were other people simply not looking at
it the same way you were in terms of optimizing
for speed and using that as the primary driver
behind the development?
John Romero: So "us" is id Software, which
is a company that I co-founded in 1991.
We started 1990, but we officially started
the company in 1991.
And that's me and John Carmack, Tom Hall,
and Adrian Carmack.
Adrian and John are not related.
And it was just us four that founded this
company.
And in 1991, which is the first year that
we were officially in our own office basically
to make games full-time, all day long, at
our own company, which is a major achievement
for us because like everybody, we have jobs,
we had day jobs, but we had created a game
in our off time and it did really well and
allowed us to basically start the company
formally.
We were doing side-scrolling games at that
time using a technique that no one had ever
used before on a PC.
It hadn't been discovered for nine years since
the introduction of the PC until John Carmack
figured out how to get pixel smooth scrolling
horizontally on a PC and it looked like a
Nintendo.
Tim Ferriss: Sorry to interrupt, could you
give an example, just for people listening,
who may not know the terminology?
I know it seems self-explanatory, but a side-scrolling
game, what would be a well-known side-scrolling
game so people can visualize?
John Romero: Yeah, Super Mario Bros. —
Tim Ferriss: Super Mario.
John Romero: — is a side-scrolling game,
and there were thousands of them throughout
the '80s, but on a computer, on a PC, and
the PC came out in August of 1981, on the
PC, no side-scrolling game could move a dot
a time horizontally.
It always moved by eight pixels.
It just chunked across the screen.
So it was very chunky and blocky when it moved.
And that's because even moving the whole screen
itself took a lot of time, but to move it
by a pixel was kind of unimaginable because
there was no way to control that at a high
speed.
So when John made the breakthrough of 1990
to figure out how to do that horizontal movement,
like a Nintendo, like Super Mario Bros. on
a Nintendo, how to do that on the PC.
That was basically the moment that id Software
was born because it was like, we are doing
this in our own company.
Oh, my God, no one has ever seen this before.
I'm just blown away.
And when we finally started the company, I
think it was half a year after that moment
when we started it, in 1991, we made 13 games
that year and we made them at high speed.
A game took us two months, but we would make
two games at a time.
So we were so busy.
The first 3D game that we made was called
Hovertank One, and that was just to get our
feet wet in 3D because we knew that 3D is
really where games are going eventually.
Because at that point there were very few
3D games and they were very, very slow.
None of them made a wall look like there were
bricks on it or rocks or whatever it was.
It was always some kind of solid color or
some little pattern of dots, two different
colored dots to make it look like another
color that doesn't really exist.
It's called dithering when you do that.
But it wasn't really advanced.
So our focus was to make the screen appear
like other games except make it so we can
move through the level smoothly, not in chunks,
and to be able to turn in any direction and
do that at a very high frame rate because
no one had ever done that before.
And that was the focus of Hovertank One and
that game was made in two months.
And that was John's big breakthrough, was
just creating the architecture of that engine
and getting the rendering for 3D going at
that speed.
Tim Ferriss: 13 games in one year.
I know nothing about game development, but
I imagine with a relatively small crew, that
sounds like a lot of games.
What do you think enabled you guys to do that
that maybe was not present for other people
working on games who had much lower output?
What were the ingredients or the approaches
or the principles, anything at all?
Maybe just tolerance for sleep deprivation.
I don't know.
What were the ingredients that allowed you
allowed you guys to do that?
John Romero: So the way that we could achieve
this game development at such high speed back
then was that when we got together as id Software,
we had already individually, other than Adrian,
who just learned how to put pixels on a computer
screen, but he was a fine artist on paper
already for his whole life, each one of us
four had 10 years of game development experience
like all the time.
And so we'd already made dozens of games each.
Tom Hall, who was our creative director, he
was a programmer, an assembly language programmer.
He made tons of adventure games.
He did action arcade games in assembly language.
So he was already a very fluent programmer.
John Carmack, of course, coded since he was
a kid.
I coded since I was 11.
So we'd been making games for 10 years and
the amount of games that we'd made was dozens
each.
And when you make that many games that quickly,
you learn how to scope, and scoping is basically
defining exactly what that game should be
and not adding to it, subtracting from it
most likely if you're going to try and get
it done.
So scoping is like, this is the amount of
time that I have, this is probably the kind
of game that we can make and how big we can
make it.
Let's do that.
And as you get closer and closer to that deadline,
you start cutting things away that you don't
need to hit that deadline.
So when we did it before meeting each other,
when we did it on our own time, we set ourselves
our own goals for finishing our own games,
and we got really good at scoping.
So when we got together and we saw what we
could do together, we also scoped together
how big those games should be, and we had
to deliver within two months.
So we had to know how good every one of us
is, how fast we can all work, and then scope
a game to that limitation.
And because we had 10 years of game dev experience,
we could just slam games out super fast, come
up with ideas, bam, start from doing the graphics,
doing the animation, programming the engine,
making the levels, making the level editors
to create levels, you name it, all the tools
that are in the background that no one sees,
to build the game data and put it together
in packages that the game can access.
There's so much technology that goes on before
you get to gameplay programming, but we were
used to doing that already for 10 years.
So it was not just the experience that we
had, but it was also the focus that we had.
We were just so happy to be able to make games
all day long as a job, which is really just
like the luckiest position ever.
So we could focus on doing that.
We could scope our games down really, really
well.
We knew what to cut when it was time to start
cutting stuff if we're getting closer to our
deadline.
And because there was no internet back then
and no one had cell phones, there was complete
and total focus because our phone never rang.
There was a phone on the wall and that thing
never rang.
So there's no interruptions.
Nobody's coming to the house and knocking
on the door in interrupting our thoughts.
So we could just focus for 12 hours a day
at least, and just code, design, you name
it, constantly.
Tim Ferriss: So to build on the emphasis you
put on scoping, which I think is certainly
applicable to so many different projects,
maybe all projects, that certainly applies
to book projects and so on that I've been
involved with, podcasts, thematically choosing
where you'll go and where you will not go.
I was doing some research, and I read a discussion
of different, I suppose, principles at id
Software, and a comment came up, which was
"No prototypes," which was attributed to you,
and talks about you guys being your own best
testing team and so on.
Can't believe everything you read on the internet,
of course, but if this is true, if you could
elaborate on what you mean by that.
John Romero: So to get that many games done
that fast, you can't be playing around with
making prototypes.
Prototypes are like, let's test this and see
if it works, and let's test that and see it
— there's no testing.
It's like, here's the game that we're going
to make, here are all the characters that
go in the game, here's how many levels we
have, here are all the pieces of the levels
that need to be drawn, here's all the animations
that need to be created, all the tools that
need to be programmed, all that stuff.
There's no way to do any prototyping if you're
going to get done in two months with four
people.
So we had no prototypes.
We knew how to code already.
So because we can just see it in our minds,
we can just visualize it, and we communicated
with each other just going, okay, it's going
to look like this on the screen.
We're going to see mountains in the background.
On the foreground, we're going to have another
plane and we're going to have trees there,
and up in the trees we're going to have these
characters and their AI is going to be limited
to blah, blah, blah, blah.
And so we just kind of describe what the game
is, and we can do that within just like, let's
say an hour.
At the very beginning of the new game, in
one hour we can describe that game extensively
for what we're going to create in the next
two months.
There wasn't like, well, then we have to figure
out this.
It was like, there's no figuring it out.
We're just making it.
So there weren't prototypes.
It was just, we're making the game.
Later on with bigger games that we could spend
more time on, we could do R&D, but we still
knew what we were making.
We just needed to figure out how to make that
part of it.
But it wasn't like we built a piece of the
game and then throw it away.
It was like we would build this functionality
in because that was the original design, and
if we found out that that functionality actually
is a detriment to the game itself or the soul
of the game, then we would remove it.
But it wasn't like we were prototyping it.
We were making that piece of technology in
the game.
It was going to be part of the game, but we
find out that that is not where the game is
really.
And then we pull it out.
But we didn't prototype.
Tim Ferriss: So let me ask, I'm sure, a naive
question, but if you are going to ensure that,
for instance, you can take an element like
that and remove it later if it is not contributing
to it or reinforcing the soul of the game,
do you need to think about that design spec
in advance so you don't end up with a piece
you want to remove, but that is interdependent
with other elements in the game?
In other words, does the architecture, how
you approach it, need to be decided in advance
so that you have the capability of removing
something in that way?
John Romero: When we're coming up with the
design of the game, let's say in this case
it's Wolfenstein 3D — and the inspiration
for Wolfenstein 3D was a 1981 game called
Castle Wolfenstein.
And it had a lot of really great gameplay
features in it that we wanted to put in Wolfenstein
3D, such as when you shoot a guard, you could
drag them and hide them around a wall.
You could search their bodies, you could go
up to storage chests and try and open them
and maybe shoot them open.
But that makes noise and might call the guards.
All these little pieces of design that we
wanted to replicate but replicate it in 3D
because Castle Wolfenstein was just a top-down
game from 1981.
It wasn't 3D, the screen didn't move around,
it was just like characters are marching around
on the screen and that's it.
They might leave the screen and disappear,
but your screen was static like many games
back in the '80s.
When we were making Wolfenstein 3D, we start
programming in the dead body, dragging and
the searching, and we started doing that.
That was the design.
So we already designed that we're doing it.
We already got the code in to do it, and we're
now doing it.
We're playing the game and we're shooting
somebody, going up and searching them.
And as we're playing the game, it feels like
that doesn't match now what this game feels
like, because the original game, it was perfect.
It matched perfectly with the way that you
moved around and the feeling of the original
game was more of a stealth game.
So Castle Wolfenstein was really the first
stealth game made.
It was an action arcade game, but it was really
primarily about stealthing around and secretly
getting out of this castle and escaping it.
And we were doing that in our game as well.
It was a recreation.
But when we got to the point where we were
doing some of the similar actions that were
not just run and gun, we knew that that is
not what this game's strength is.
The strength of this game is doing this never
before seen high speed rendering and high
speed movement through this maze.
And no one had seen that before.
And slowing you down and making the players
stop to do something else was anti the focus
of the game.
So the focus became this is the soul of the
game.
The soul of this game is high speed, run and
gun.
Anything that stops you needs to come out.
So even though we programmed in that stuff,
we pulled it out because it wasn't true to
the new spirit of the game, the one that we
were making.
It was like the original game's idea was transferred
to our game, but all of the details of those
two games are different.
The way that you shoot enemies in the original
Castle Wolfenstein was not the way that you
do it in our game.
Our game is much more fluid and simple and
easy to control and very, very fast.
And so when we started focusing our design
in that part of it, we started removing everything
that took away from that speed.
But there were some things that we had to
leave in, like to open a door and wait for
the door to open, that's actually suspense
that we need in the game.
And if we didn't have any doorways, you're
just running through a maze just blowing everything
away constantly nonstop, but you have no suspense
really.
One of the original games' focuses was the
suspense of wondering if you'd made a noise
and alerted the guards to come after you,
or if they heard you trying to open a chest
in the next room and you can see them in the
next room and you're just trying to open a
chest and if you shoot it, then they're coming
in the room and they're going to try and arrest
you.
So we had a new focus of our design and that's
why we start removing and changing it.
Tim Ferriss: So let me build on Wolfenstein
3D, and I have a question from a friend of
mine because I mentioned to him that we were
going to be speaking, his name is Elan Lee,
he's the co-founder, co-creator of Exploding
Kittens, not just the single game, but the
company that produces many, many tabletop
games and card games.
And he said, "Holy crap, amazing.
Ask him how the pressure of promising the
world a game when he didn't have one somehow
cajoled the cells of his body to do the impossible
and will one into existence?"
And we went back and forth a little bit and
he said, "Let me know if you needed any links
to early Romero development stories.
That guy literally did the impossible."
So could you expand on what he means by promising
the world a game when he didn't have one,
and how that cajoled the cells in your body?
That may not be the right way to put it, but
to do the impossible, just for people who
don't have any of that background.
John Romero: We made Wolfenstein 3D.
For me personally, that was my 87th game that
I'd made.
Right after Wolfenstein 3D, we made Spear
of Destiny.
That took us two months.
That was number 88.
There was a game called ShadowCaster that
used our technology that we had made.
So all the tools that I wrote, all any gameplay
code, menu code, all the stuff, we licensed
our technology and give it to another company
and then they make a game.
That's game number 89 called ShadowCaster.
And then game number 90, not that I even was
counting back then, it was just like, next
game, we're going to make the next game.
At the time, at very end of 1992, after making
all of these games, and really when Wolfenstein
came out, everything changed because now we
have high-speed 3D.
No one had ever seen this before.
Ultima Underworld was out, and it was a really
great roleplaying game set in 3D, but the
3D let you turn your head and look up and
down and all that stuff, which really slowed
the game down.
So it wasn't the high-speed game.
You would step slowly through a dungeon, but
it was 3D.
3D is now happening at this point.
If it's not ours, it's probably slow, but
it is 3D because the world is now going to
become 3D, but it's hard to get to that point.
Our focus was speed.
That was where we wanted to live.
So with the next game, we had had such massive
success with Wolfenstein and Spear of Destiny
that we jumped basically to the front of the
industry with those games.
Immediately, bam, we are now in the lead because
nobody was making this, and this was the new
thing.
High speed 3D is the future, we're there first
and we need to keep our lead.
The planning for our next game after that,
and our planning was happening at the end
of 1992, was the creation of the engine that
was a Wolfenstein-plus engine after Spear
of Destiny.
It led to ShadowCaster, but that engine's
architecture was too limiting for what we
had in mind for our next game.
So that's why we licensed that technology
out and decided we are not using that 3D engine
architecture anymore.
And so at that point, we'd made four 3D games,
four games in full 3D, high speed, all that.
For our fifth game we needed a new architecture
and to come up with a list of all of the things
that this new game would do, and we were thinking,
we need to go beyond anything we've ever seen.
And this was the only time we ever did this,
the next game needs to be the best game we
could imagine playing, that there can't be
a better game in the world than this game.
What would that game have?
So we made a list, a bullet point list of
all the things that this new game should have.
Obviously it needs to have light and dark,
it has to have light levels, it needs to be
spooky, it needs to have bright areas, which
we had no lighting in Wolfenstein.
It was just full bright.
The lights were always on.
So we need lighting control.
We need height control.
We need to be able to go up and down stairs,
we need to have giant tall rooms, really cramped
rooms.
We need walls to be drawn at any angle, which
no game in history had ever done at that point
where you can have a wall that's at an angle
in a wall that's jagged and all that.
Every game before this next game was basically
a maze game.
And when you look at a maze from above, it's
just 90 degree wall curve turns.
It's like those classic mazes, labyrinths,
where you're just drawing a line through the
maze.
That's what every single game from the '70s
until that point looked like.
Wolfenstein 3D was a high speed maze game.
It was the same thing.
90 degree corners all over the place.
So this next game would break that barrier.
So we're going to have what we call non-orthogonal
walls that could create a space that no one
had seen before.
We were going to make this game multiplayer
so people could play with each other and against
each other for the first time because right
then, local area networks, they were just
barely starting to sell network cards and
the cables and all that stuff in all the computer
retail stores.
So we would make a game that would take advantage
of a network if you ever had it, and it would
take advantage of the modem to play against
or with your friends.
And then we would also make the game open
so people could change the game to do whatever
they wanted and make it their own, basically.
They could make levels, they could make new
sounds, new graphics.
They could change the whole game basically
and mod it.
It's called mods, modification.
So we would open it up to modders who wanted
to create a new experience using the tech
that we created, and we would also give away
the first piece of this game for free into
the world, and you don't have to pay for it.
You just get it, and if you like it, you had
fun, if you want more, then you buy it from
us.
That's called shareware.
So we did all of these.
We had this whole list of everything we're
going to do, and we were very confident that
we could do it because John was already planning
the architecture of the engine, he already
was very confident in how he was going to
be able to do that.
And at that point, we were just on top of
the world.
We had just conquered everything with Wolfenstein
3D and with Spear of Destiny.
And so we're just invincible feeling.
So what we did was we took our two-week vacation
at the end of 1992, and we came back in January
of '93 at the beginning of the year, and we're
going to start working on this new game that
we called DOOM.
And we decided for some reason that we were
going to put out a press release and tell
everybody what's going to be in this game,
and it will be the greatest game that Earth
has seen.
And we did.
We put a press release out before we even
start writing the game.
We put a press release out saying, this will
be the best game anyone has ever played on
a PC, and this is what's going to be in it,
and it's a breakthrough in game technology
and all this crazy stuff.
We put a press release out saying that.
So we needed to fulfill that.
And so we started working on it.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
John Romero: Crazy.
Crazy.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's nuts.
So there are, for instance, as thought exercises,
some companies that will write press releases
in advance of developing a technology product
to help hone their focus on various elements,
but that is for internal use only.
You guys actually put out the press release.
What was the conversation around the press
release?
Because it's a smart team, there was some
thought, I'm sure, that went into that decision.
What was the logic, if there was one behind
putting out the press release?
John Romero: I don't know why we would've
put out a press release.
It doesn't make any sense.
But I think that what happened is Wolfenstein
3D came out — remember at this point, we
were so used to making games extremely fast.
With Wolfenstein, that was the very first
game that we could make in any amount of time
that we wanted.
There was no deadline on Wolfenstein.
We made the shareware version of Wolfenstein
in four months and uploaded it.
So there was four of us — well, mostly,
three of us — oh, no, sorry, there was four
of us making Wolfenstein.
We had Kevin Cloud in there for the very last
month to add graphics and do a bunch of other
cool stuff.
But we were very fast and we didn't have a
deadline on that game.
And it released in May, the shareware.
So we had the rest of 1992 just building up
this world domination of Wolfenstein.
There was an internet top 100 list of games
every week, and Wolfenstein was at the top
for the entire year after it came out.
It was huge.
So we were just on top of the world, but after
we released Spear of Destiny, it came out,
I believe in September of 1992, and no one
had heard anything from us in three months,
which back then with these accelerated schedules
and people wanting to know what we're doing,
we're finally now doing interviews with places.
We're doing radio interviews.
We have the local TV station in our office
interviewing us and recording our screens.
We have them interviewing our publishers.
People wanted all kinds of information about
what we were doing.
So I think at that time it was like, let's
put out a press release telling people what
we're going to start working on, because everyone
is asking us constantly what we're doing next.
So let's just do a press release.
And it's equal information for everyone.
It's not like there's an exclusive with this
one computer magazine, Computer Gaming World
or something.
There was no exclusive.
It was, "Here, everybody, this is what we're
working on, and now we have to dive back down
in the ocean and start making it.
Don't bug us."
So I think the press release was probably
to let everyone know what we're going to do
next.
Tim Ferriss: That's incredible.
All right.
So I want to take a pause here just for a
second to ask you about — tell me if I'm
pronouncing this correctly.
Hyperthymesia?
Am I getting that right?
John Romero: Yeah, that's right.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
So could you just define this for folks?
And my question is also to what extent this
has been an asset and to what extent this
has had maybe a shadow side or been detrimental
in any way?
So if you could just explain what it is and
then hop into that.
John Romero: Yeah, hyperthymesia is a memory
disorder where the person with hyperthymesia
has a superior autobiographical recall.
And it ranges from really good recall of significant
events and things that happened in your life
that most people would forget over time.
With hyperthymesia, you never forget those
things.
They just don't go away.
You wouldn't know it if you're young, but
as you get older and you start to lose decades
of memories because you don't use them and
they're not significant anymore, hyperthymesia,
you don't lose them.
They're always there.
And the extreme end of hyperthymesia is where
you remember every second of your life since
you got hyperthymesia, and it could be born
with, but sometimes it is an induced memory
disorder.
So people have been hit in the head with a
baseball and boom, they have hyperthymesia
and they record every second of their life,
which gets to be kind of insane because everything
that you've ever done is always present in
your brain.
And having all of these thoughts, all of these
memories constantly, it's a big hindrance,
I guess, in just normal operation like just
living.
My hyperthymesia is really — I remember
basically everything that has happened to
me, mostly all the significant stuff and things
that are connected to it.
So like music and movies and programming and
games and that kind of stuff, I would remember
basically all of that stuff through all the
years.
And things that I cared about, I would remember
those things.
I would remember the names of people who wrote
games, when those games were published, the
year that they were published, all of that
stuff.
So I would remember everything.
So it makes it a lot easier to just say, "Hey,
what happened in 1983 when you were doing
blah, blah, blah?"
And I was like, "Well, I was actually programming
this stuff, but I didn't have my computer,
so I had to do it on paper in the kitchen
and [inaudible]."
I could tell people what I did whenever.
Tim Ferriss: Have you had that, to the best
of your knowledge, since birth or was that
induced at some point?
John Romero: I think I've had it mostly since
birth, but it got stronger when I started
to learn how to code at really high speed
after getting the computer in the house.
I was learning so much, so fast.
I actually had to take breaks from learning
because my head was just packed full of stuff
and it needed to settle, and I had to stop
myself from learning for a day or two before
I could jump back in and fill my head full
of stuff again.
And due to the nature of what I was learning
in the early '80s, which is learning every
byte of memory in an entire computer, because
back then, the knowledge of language wasn't
as important as the knowledge of hardware
at that time.
So I needed to learn all of the hardware of
the computer that I was programming and then
the languages on top of that, and then start
creating off of the top of that information.
So that was also forcing function to induce
memory of everything basically that was happening.
Tim Ferriss: I have one family member who
has, almost certainly, I never had heard this
term before, but hyperthymesia.
He can recall just about every fact, every
experience, significant or trivial, from his
past.
So he's much older than I am but can recall
the seating arrangement in every class that
he was ever in, every word of every foreign
language he's ever studied, et cetera.
And what I've seen is that, that is a superpower
on so many levels but also, as an example,
has been challenging for him because negative
experiences, arguments, let's just say slight
moral injuries, all of these things are also
as ever present for him and it's very challenging.
And I'm wondering if you have seen any, I
don't want to say trade-offs, but challenges
related to having such an enhanced memory
besides what you've mentioned.
John Romero: I'd say that's totally true for
a lot of people that have that.
For me, a lot of it is that the, say, negative/hindrance
would be that, I think a lot of things are
similar in importance even if they aren't.
So I would think that this possibly insignificant
detail is more important than anyone else
would think.
And the reason why I think it is because the
way it's connected to other things.
It's like if that didn't happen then these
other things wouldn't have happened as well,
you know?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
John Romero: Yeah.
So it's like not knowing, well, say, for this
book, what's important and what isn't important.
But it was really important, then I went to
the heavy metal concert with this person.
Tim Ferriss: So I could see that being — has
that been challenging in group environments,
team environments where you're trying to weigh
the relative significance but because, in
your mind, some of these elements that might
not be deemed important by other people are
sort of importance-adjacent, so you weigh
them more heavily?
Has that been challenging in team environments
at all?
John Romero: Not really, because I think the
most helpful part of that is just knowing
what has been made before, what games and
game design techniques, programming techniques,
approaches to certain control issues, like
that stuff.
Having that and luckily just having played
so many games over so long a time, that has
been really helpful to be able to recall solutions
or other approaches people have taken that
we don't need to research or figure it out
again, reinvent the wheel.
It's like this game in 1984 did this on an
Atari 800, and we might be able to do that
on the PC or something like that.
So it was more helpful to solving issues or
being able to make sure that we're not replicating
failed designs of the past and that we were
always creating new things I hadn't seen before,
which was really helpful.
Tim Ferriss: How important, or how much of
a contributor do you think to the ongoing
success of the team was having two games,
and therefore two options, for things to work
on at any given point in time?
John Romero: I would say that having two games
at a time was not — it did not impact really
anything because we knew what each of the
games was, what we were doing on both those
games.
One of those games came out a month before
the other game, so that was the priority.
But what we did was we divided our time into
two roughly eight-hour days or seven-hour
days.
So we would go from 10:00 to 6:00 on one game
and then 6:00 to 2:00 on the next game.
So we would just all shift because it was
really important to be in sync with each other.
When we needed to ask questions or whatever,
we were all on a project, and it wasn't like,
"Oh, you're just making a level for the other
game.
Well, I guess I can't ask you."
It was like we were always in sync.
So we would shift to the next game and start
working on that.
And then the next day we start back on the
other game.
And the reason why we're doing eight hours
and eight hours or seven and seven was because
we love making games.
We wanted to get these games done.
We're learning a ton.
It was super fun being together and making
these games.
We'd be laughing.
It would be new things that we're inventing.
It was like being in a lab where things are
going right all the time.
So it was super fun and we could do those
hours without a problem.
And we did it for a whole year.
All of 1991 was spent with all the hours that
we were awake working on games, two games
at a time at least.
Because we were in sync at the same time when
we shifted projects, we didn't get creative
block with something.
It's like, "Ah, I can't even figure out what
I'm going to do at this level.
I'm going to just make a level for the other
game."
We would help each other if anyone got stuck.
It's like, "You know what?
I don't know what I'm going to do for this
one section."
And I'm like, "Well, put a meat grinder in
there or something."
And it's like, "Oh, yeah, good idea."
So we would help each other.
But most of the time we already knew what
we were doing.
We kind of freethought everything out before
we started working on these games, and we
could do it at really high speed.
So we just executed because that was the really
important part.
We had got the ideas, and we have lots of
experience, and it was all about the execution
of our ideas and in sync.
And luckily, because we had such a small team
of four people, that could happen very fast.
The bigger the team gets, the harder and longer
it takes to make one vision come out the right
way, but with four people to have very distinct
jobs to do, it works really, really well.
Tim Ferriss: DOOM, we paused at the press
release.
You go on to create DOOM.
When did you, after its release, or maybe
in the course of developing it, realize, "Holy
shit, this is a monster or it's going to be
a monster.
This is going to be bigger than even our grandest
press releases could have predicted."
Was there a moment or an event, a day, anything,
that comes to mind?
John Romero: Well, several things happened
during the development that were interesting
in that respect.
We knew at the very beginning of making the
game that it was going to be the greatest
game that we've ever played because that was
our focus of — why we're making the game.
So we already knew it was going to be awesome
and the best game that we had ever played.
That was already a given.
But while we're making the game, we got to
a point when Tom Hall left the team in August
of 1993, and we brought in Sandy Petersen
to replace him doing level design work.
And then I basically took over as the game
designer of the game.
And that's how we started stripping a lot
of stuff out of the game like lives and score
and getting rid of items that didn't matter,
really streamlining the design.
Sandy was making levels, and at this point,
the design language for the level creation
was figured out because I needed to solve
that problem with like, "What are our levels
going to look like that maximizes the use
of our technology that no one has seen and
creates spaces no one has ever experienced
before in a way that is kind of drastic and
not a little bit better than Wolfenstein 3D?"
It needed to be drastically better than Wolfenstein
3D.
So that took some work to come up with this
abstract level design style.
And when that happened and we started to make
stuff, it's like, "Okay.
This is looking really great," Sandy Petersen
immediately started picking up that style
because I would sit and talk to him at the
very beginning about — like, "Here's what
is important about using this technology that
makes us stand out."
And so he started putting those elements in
his levels.
And when I got to run Sandy's levels, not
mine — because when I make my own levels,
I know everything that's in it.
So I'm just testing to make sure it looks
good, it's working well, the enemies are doing
what I want to do, the pacing is correct.
When combat happens is when I want it to happen.
When exploration happens, I have the area
cleared for the player to do that, all of
these things.
But when I play Sandy's levels for the first
time, I know nothing about it.
And I remember the first time when I started
playing his levels, I knew what people were
going to feel like.
Finally, right?
Tim Ferriss: Right.
John Romero: And it was like, "Wow, this is
scary."
I'm going through this level, and I'm hearing
these monsters moving around.
I don't know where they're at, but I don't
like that they're coming for me somehow.
And it was great because I finally got to
feel in a game design, feel the game experience
way what people would feel when they're playing
it.
Now, at that point, I'm so used to the technology
that it's like whatever.
Even though it was like it changed everything,
no one had seen a screen that looked this
way, for us, it was just like another day
at work, whatever.
So I was just focused on the experience part
of it.
So that to me was really fun to play a level
I didn't make and experience in a little way
what people were going to feel like.
And then we got to a point where it's early
October and I, for some reason, look at that
press release again and look at the bullet
points because I'm just like as a producer
type person, I need to make sure we're putting
everything in the game.
We didn't promise stuff that we didn't deliver
on, and we need to mostly get that bullet
point list done.
And I saw that we were missing multiplayer.
We didn't even think about it.
We thought about it in January, but we get
to the point of the game where the game is
mostly done now, and it's early October.
And I'm like, "Whoa.
Yeah.
Whoo.
There's no multiplayer."
I go and I tell John, I'm like, "You will
not believe this.
Yeah, there's no multiplayer.
Remember, we're going to do that?"
And he is like, "Oh, yeah."
John's a genius.
And so John figured out.
He kind of immediately in his brain was just
like, "Oh, we'll just solve it with a peer-to-peer
networking model."
So he figured out how he's going to bolt multiplayer
onto the game and make it feel like it's been
there the whole time.
And so it just took him a few hours.
He just needed to learn how to get network
packets going between computers over our network,
and then how to get the game.
What data does he send between computers?
He's trying to minimize the amount of data
so it's fast.
And he learned within just hours the techniques
that he needed to do.
And it took a couple days to hammer out some
of the speed issues, but it was fast work
before.
I'd seen him shoot a character.
He had two computers going and he's moving
a character in one screen, the other one,
you see the guy running around inside the
level, it's like, "Oh, my God.
We've never seen this before in any game."
And then you shoot him and the guy dies, and
it's like, "Oh, my God, this is going to be
the most fun thing in the world."
And I go back into my office, and I get that
code running on my machine and we just start
shooting each other, and it's like, "This
is nuts.
Oh, my God."
And then I'm imagining the level I'm currently
working on and seeing two people fighting
in another room from my viewpoint.
And I'm just like, "There's nothing like this
on Earth.
Oh, my God, this is changing everything."
So I got so excited at that point.
So that was another like, "Holy shit, this
is going to be so different and blow everybody
away and change everything."
So multiplayer was — when I saw that, and
this is October, and so that was really amazing.
And then the lead up to when we're about to
release the game, we're not online talking
to anybody, but somehow people knew we were
getting close.
We were starting to get random phone calls
at the office.
There's these weird subcultures going on in
Usenet around DOOM and people creating games
based on DOOM being the best game that could
ever be made.
And then creating a really crude version of
that and calling it Smashing Pumpkins Into
Small Piles Of Putrid Debris.
And because that was such a funny thing, we
put it as a cheat code in DOOM.
Just there was a lot of internet activity
around the fact that we're about to release
the game, and we never said anything.
So it was really weird that the world was
starting to go nuts before we launched the
game.
And that was the third like, "Okay."
But up until that point, every game that we
made, we would put it out and then our plan
is to just wipe that game out with the next
one.
Like the next game, we're going to destroy
that thing.
So it's like boom, game's out, next.
So we never thought that DOOM was going to
be living actively for 30 years, which is
this year, it'll be 30 years old.
Stuff is being made for the game on a daily
basis all the time.
In one of the greatest mods that has been
created was released not that long ago, this
year.
Incredible.
It's called MyHouse.WAD.
People are still making insane stuff for the
game.
But we never thought that was going to happen.
We just thought we were going to make a really
great game and the next game's going to wipe
it out.
That was it.
That was the goal.
Tim Ferriss: Let's hop back to something that
you mentioned in passing that you left in
1996.
Could you tell the story of how that came
to be, how you ended up leaving the company?
John Romero: We started making the last game
that I had worked on, at id Softwares named
Quake, and we started working on Quake in
1995 as a team.
John had already kind of started planning
the technology at the end of '94 when we were
finishing DOOM II.
He was exploring the technology for the next
game, which was going to be a massive, massive
jump in technology.
And so when we started as a team in 1995 to
make Quake, it was like making DOOM, it was
like, here's this giant mountain we got to
climb again.
There's a lot of tools, there's a lot of foundational
work that has to get done and let's do it.
So we just started working on it, and the
design of the game also was like, remember
we started making Quake and we couldn't because
the tech wasn't going to be there, but this
now was going to be the tech that we could
use to make Quake, which is why we named it
Quake.
So it's like, we're going to do that game.
That game was a medieval 3D adventure with
combat.
It wasn't a first-person shooter because that
never existed at that time.
It was going to be a 3D action, medieval.
We were going to recreate our D&D adventures
that we had and put it in full 3D, in a real,
full-3D game.
So that was the design.
And as I am making the level editor and kind
of experimenting with 3D, there's a lot of
other stuff going on at the company because
DOOM changed the planet and then DOOM II again
was even better than the original DOOM.
It was crazy because we only had at the time
when we shipped DOOM where it was only six
of us and on top of that, we had three other
people in the company to handle business,
all of the managerial type stuff and all of
the technical support type stuff.
Tim Ferriss: That's incredible.
It's just so wild.
John Romero: It was a very small company.
And working on Quake, we had gotten our team
up to 10 eventually to make Quake and still
with the other three people I think on top
of that.
The company was 13 people when Quake launched.
So we had a very small team and we had the
world coming at us, and there was so much
to deal with DOOM's impact and the articles,
the hint guides, the strategy guides, the
other projects that we had going that it took
up a lot of time, which wasn't bad because
at that time there was a lot of technology
creation for Quake going on.
And I was creating the level editor for the
level design team to start experimenting with,
and it was really just two other people on
the team doing level design in full 3D for
the first time.
And that was Sandy Petersen and American McGee.
So it was still pretty small.
We still had more people eventually to hire
onto the team to get us to 10 by the time
Quake was shipped.
But at this time there was probably seven
of us.
It was pretty small.
During that time the design that of that medieval
game kept getting stronger and stronger.
It was getting reinforced with more things
that could be done to reinforce the feeling
of that medieval world and do new things that
we hadn't seen a game do at that time in lots
of different ways.
So it was becoming a really strong design,
really strong, really cool.
And the problem was that we were spending
all of that year kind of spinning our wheels,
doing 3D levels, little pieces of levels and
stuff, but we didn't have a gameplay programmer
that could actually do anything in the game
because the engine wasn't ready.
We're waiting for that engine to actually
happen so we could start using it.
Tim Ferriss: John, can I pause you for one
second?
Just for people who hear this word but may
not understand how it applies within game
development, could you just define engine?
In simple terms, what is an engine?
John Romero: So at this point in our game
development, we had created this term called
engine.
And the engine is what drives the game, and
that is the thing that puts the images up
on the screen.
It's the thing that loads files and saves
files.
It's the thing that takes input in and makes
gameplay happen.
It's what makes sound come out and music come
out of the game.
And so the core functionality that is needed
for a game to run without any of the graphics
and any of the actual sound effects themselves,
the core technology is called an engine.
Because you can put the data in and it will
come out, it will play.
You put sound effects in, and then you use
game in gameplay code, you define when those
will play and they come out.
And so it's an entire set of code that any
game can be made from.
So it's called an engine.
And we pioneered the idea of an engine in
1990 with our original Commander Keen game.
We started calling it an engine even before
we launched Keen.
So we start that idea in 1990.
Now we're talking about 1995, which we'd made
a lot of games since 1990, 20 something games.
So with Quake, we're creating a new engine,
one that can do full 3D, one that has a completely
different look to it, has more advanced gameplay
code.
Everything about it was different.
When we got to November of that year, the
engine was finally ready, but the team was
burnt out because of the massive effort that
it took to create the technology and the fact
that they'd been making a lot of data that
couldn't be used because the engine changed
so much that what they made was too primitive.
The engine could do more than what they had
created.
Because every time we were making stuff for
the game, the engine would be at a certain
point of speed and we're modifying our levels
to make it run well at that speed.
But that means it's a little too primitive
because the engine got faster and faster and
faster.
And by the time we reached November, we could
render much more interesting views in the
world, but we didn't build those worlds yet.
We were slowly inching towards them.
So it was a lot of like, wow, all the stuff
I worked on can't really use it.
So people were burned out from that, and the
team did not feel like they were up to the
task of doing research on a new style of game,
which is what Quake was going to be.
It was not going to be a first-person shooter.
They basically suggested that we should just
make a shooter because we know how to do it.
We can nail it.
This is brand new tech that's awesome already.
If we just do a shooter, we can all just ship
a game and take a rest kind of thing.
And I was just like, "No, we need to do this.
The whole world knows what this game is.
It's in magazines.
Everybody knows what Quake is, and this is
what I'm all about is we're pushing our technology
to the limit.
Let's push design to the limit too.
Let's go beyond what we've done before and
make something new people haven't seen."
I wanted to make this 3D game experience something
no one had seen before that goes beyond our
first-person shooter.
You know, our forte, our expertise was in
shooters, so how can we go beyond the shooter
and do something that incorporates elements
of that that goes beyond it?
And so they just really didn't want to do
another unknowable mountain to climb.
When is it going to be defined?
We don't have a scope that has an end on it
now.
We didn't either with the engine and we didn't
change course while we're doing it either,
which is what really harmed the team.
So I basically just gave in and said, "I will
design a first-person shooter that will use
all of this stuff and what we've done to date
to the best that we can, and then release
it as fast as we possibly can."
So we started doing that from the middle of
November.
We basically went into crunch mode at that
time, even though everyone's burned out.
They were mostly burned out because they weren't
making something that they could see what
it was going to be used for.
And because we wanted to get it done as fast
as possible, we went into what's called crunch
mode, which at that time was seven days a
week, all the hours that you can, which is
at least 10 a day.
And we did that for seven months, seven days
a week.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, my God.
John Romero: And it was really hard.
And after the game was released, it was like
a month and a half before I quit because there
was still some work for me to get the game
mastered and created to go into stores and
be shipped to customers, that kind of thing.
I took a vacation, I came back, I mastered
all that stuff, and I was already planning
for half a year to leave because if we're
not going to commit ourselves to furthering
design, it's just going to become a technology
company, then I want to leave and go create
a design company.
And so I've already planned after that big
meeting about a month later, two months later,
already planned to leave and start another
company with Tom Hall.
And he agreed that he would love to do that.
So I said, after shipping Quake, then we'll
start doing that.
So that's what happened.
After shipping, I started getting in touch
with publishers and they also—John Carmack
mainly—didn't want to work with me anymore,
so they asked for my resignation.
I was like, "Well, I'm going anyway, so let's
sign it."
But it was a very tough game to get through.
Tim Ferriss: What was that experience of separating
from the company like for you?
Was it challenging?
Was it strange to be on your own and to leave
behind maybe the identity that you had built
with that team?
What was that experience just emotionally,
psychologically for you?
John Romero: Leaving and starting another
company, I was very excited about it.
I was excited because I was going to be doing
this with Tom, who's a really great friend,
amazing creative force, someone super fun
to work with.
And we both had tons and tons of experience.
So I was really excited about that.
But I really liked working with the other
people at it as well.
So it was really, it sucked, but it was also
exciting, like at the same time.
It was like that was a lot of really great
work there but I'm also excited about what
I can possibly do with without limitations
on what, say, design could do.
So it was negatives and positives, but I think
that it was mostly positive because we're
starting to do something new.
And that was really, really fun to do with
Tom.
And we spent about half a year building relationships
with different publishers to start Ion Storm.
And finally after six months, figure out who
we're going to side with and signed up with
Eidos.
Tim Ferriss: What led you to want to write
your memoir, DOOM Guy: Life in First Person?
What were the reasons for wanting to write
this book and publish this book?
John Romero: So several years ago, I went
to do a speaking engagement in Canada, and
they basically had heard the story of DOOM's
development and already knew some of the stuff
I talked about.
So they said, "Can you do something different?
Can you tell us about your early life and
what made you the person that would make DOOM.
Instead talking about DOOM talk about how
you became the person to make DOOM."
So it was like, oh, kind of my life in games,
early games.
So it's like, all right, I'll write that talk.
So I basically wrote a talk that had a lot
of the stuff that happened in my early childhood
with all of the exciting things that had to
do with drugs and murders and just the low
income stuff, which kind of shocked people.
They had never heard any of that before.
And hearing the audience and the questions
later was just like people saying, "You should
put in a book.
Nobody knows about that information."
I was like, "Yeah, I didn't really ever talk
about it before."
And that would be a good idea in fact, because
I haven't seen anything out there that really
documents software's ludography, really like
what game started on what date, when did that
game ship, what's the authoritative book on
the development of all of this software?
Stuff I could actually put that in this history
as well.
So it was kind of a twofold reason for writing
the book was to get the whole story out there
from when I was born until today, and to also
be a really great chronicle for everything
that happened during those years, and when
those things happened, and a bunch of the
cool stories that people hadn't heard before,
and just put a lot of really good stuff in
there as well.
There was a game that I was working on called
Blackroom, and every once in a while I get
people asking, "So what's up with Blackroom?"
And I always tell them, "I can't talk about
Blackroom."
Well, Blackroom's in this book.
So people are going to get to hear everything
about Blackroom.
Tim Ferriss: Is it true that DOOM, the name,
comes from The Color of Money, or is the origin
a different origin story for the name?
John Romero: Yeah, the name for DOOM came
from John Carmack.
He was watching Tom Cruise's The Color of
Money movie and when he was watching it and
he saw that the guy walk up to Tom Cruise,
he's got his cue stick inside of this case
on his lap.
And the guy's like, "What's in there?"
And Tom Cruise looks down at it and looks
up at the guy and goes, "It's doom."
He was like, "Wow, that's a really great name."
We hadn't heard of a game called DOOM before.
So he said, "How about DOOM?"
And I was like, "That is awesome.
Yeah."
Tim Ferriss: And that was it.
The rest is history.
So John, people can find you on Twitter @romero,
on Instagram @theromero.
Thank you for taking the time.
And is there anything else that you'd like
to mention?
Any other asks or requests of the audience,
anything at all that you'd like to mention
before we bring this to a close?
John Romero: Well, I mean, I'm really grateful
to have had a really fun career making games.
It's been a blast from the early days of learning
how to program a computer all the way to today
using really advanced technology to make shooters
with bigger teams.
I've seen everything that's happened during
that huge span of time, and it's been just
a really, really, really great time overall.
So I'm just really just happy to have had
that kind of a life.
And all of that is basically in this book.
Tim Ferriss: Excellent.
So John, thank you so much for taking the
time and I am looking forward to getting a
copy of DOOM Guy.
People will be able to find it where books
are sold.
And we'll link to everything in the show notes
as per usual to all my fine listeners at tim.blog/podcast.
And until next time, be just a little bit
kinder to yourself and to others.
And as always, thanks for tuning in.